[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
officer lucky
started to say something about don't do
that don't tense up stop doing that
and then
it just went
chaotic kim potter takes the stand in
her own defense for the shooting death
of dante wright plus investigators get a
warrant for alec baldwin's cell phone
looking for clues in the fatal shooting
on the set of rust and after months of
testimony an end may be in sight in the
trial for former theranos ceo elizabeth
holmes and later day 12 in galaine
maxwell's federal trial in new york the
defense may be forced to rest sooner
than expected law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome to law and crime daily i'm
angenette levy in for brian buckmeyer
and with me as always is co-host terry
austin well the defense has rested its
case in the trial of kim potter this is
day eight of her manslaughter trial in
minneapolis minnesota now potter told
the jury as she took the stand in her
own defense about her extensive
background and her police training
before she went into detail about what
exactly happened on april 11th that was
the day that she shot and killed dante
wright
now potter told the jury about being in
the car
with the officer she was training right
before the traffic stop she told the
jury what happened after they pulled
over wright's car potter testified about
the officer attempting to arrest wright
when they found a warrant for a weapons
charge after running his name through
the police computer database videos
captured on body camera show the
officers got into a struggle with wright
and then potter described what happened
next
they're still struggling and i can see
sergeant johnson and
the driver
struggling over the gear shifts because
i can see
johnson's hand and then i can see his
face
he
had a look of fear on his face
it's nothing i'd seen before
did you say anything when you saw this
what did you do we were struggling we
were trying to keep him from driving
away
it just it just went
chaotic i it
and then
i
remember yelling teaser taser taser
and nothing happened
and then
he told me i shot him
now potter faces first and second degree
manslaughter charges stemming from the
shooting death of right during the
traffic stop in brooklyn center
minnesota that's just a short distance
away from minneapolis after officers
determined wright had a warrant out for
his arrest body cam footage shows
officers attempting to take him into
custody there was a struggle between
wright and the officers wright gets back
into his car that's when potter shoots
him in the chest as his car sped away
and hit another car wright died potter
maintains she accidentally pulled her
handgun instead of her taser and there's
been a debate over whether her use of
force was justified now questioning
continued into friday afternoon with
cross-examination from the prosecution
the state focused on potter's training
and annual use of force training the
prosecution then moved to a topic
touched on by several witnesses
potter's firearm and her taser and the
differences between them and then
potter was asked specifically about what
happened on april 11th
you'd agree that as a police officer you
have the duty to
render aid
and communicate information to other
officers right
yes
and it's part of your job to assist
those who are hurt or injured
true
yes
and to communicate to other officers
what you know about a particular scene
right
yes give them whatever information you
can to help them do their jobs to help
render assistance things like that right
yes but you didn't do any of those
things on april 11th did you
no you stopped doing your job completely
you didn't communicate what happened
over the radio right
no
you didn't make sure
any officers knew what you had just done
right
no you didn't run down the street and
try to save dante wright's life did you
no
he didn't check on the other car that
had been hit did you
that all happened just down the road
from you
you were focused on
what you had done because you had just
killed somebody i'm sorry it happened
[Music]
closing arguments in the case are set
for monday and you can watch them live
on the law and crime trial network now
joining terry and i is taylor coss he's
a former prosecutor and currently works
as a defense attorney so taylor i'll
start with you
how did kim potter do on the stand
hi ladies thank you it's a pleasure to
be here with you uh this evening you
know it was certainly emotional an
emotional tour de force so to speak um
but you know it's interesting if you
really think about it like what is the
defense what is her defense and her
defense in theory is that she was
justified in using it because of fear um
i'm not sure that that came across what
did come across is a sympathetic person
who clearly does appear to be sorry for
what she did but also when i watched the
cross-examination and i realized how
quickly she fell apart right in the
middle of the stressful situation how
she was no longer able to do her job or
do even the most basic functions of a
police officer i wondered to myself how
did she ever get this job and it's
really just a tragedy
it really is a tragedy taylor i couldn't
have put it any better and it really
does appear that she panicked when she
said she saw the look on the other
officer's face she said he looked very
scared so um she she obviously panicked
terry i'm wondering do you think that
kim potter's
testimony was effective for her
antoinette i think she was not effective
as a matter of fact i think she hurt her
case the video spoke volumes it was very
effective it really showed her as
someone who had remorse but when she was
on that stand she came across as being
evasive she actually refused to admit
even the smallest thing that the
prosecution was trying to get her to say
so i think it makes it look like to the
jury that she's trying to be somewhat
you know evasive with her answers and
she also is blaming everyone else you
know she blamed lucky for stopping the
car in the first place she blamed the
department for saying that they didn't
train her well enough so i don't think
she was effective i think she came
across poorly
very interesting take from terry and
taylor
so it'll be interesting to see what the
jury does with this when they get that
case probably sometime late monday
afternoon we're going to move on now to
the commonwealth of kentucky and that is
where a former police detective who
fired the shot that killed brianna
taylor last year remains off the force
after a review board upheld his
termination in may of 2020 officer miles
cosgrove was part of a drug raid
involving taylor's ex-boyfriend at her
home it was early morning and 26 year
old taylor was asleep with her boyfriend
that is when plainclothes officers
barged into her apartment taylor's
boyfriend kenneth walker had a license
to carry a weapon and he actually
believed that someone was breaking into
their home
and that is when taylor or when walker
rather fired a single shot wounding an
officer and then as officers returned
fire cosgrove shot 16 times killing
taylor cosgrove's chief at the time said
the officer violated standard operating
procedures and did not activate his body
worn camera no charges have been filed
related to taylor's death but another
officer brent hankinson faces
endangerment charges for firing his
weapon at neighboring apartments
now still ahead on law and crime daily
the fraud trial for a silicon valley
businesswoman elizabeth holmes it may
come to an end very soon as we near
verdict watch
and then later on we are going to talk
about alec baldwin the shooting death
investigation on the set of rust police
want to search alec baldwin's phone
we'll have that and more after the break
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back a settlement has been
reached in a civil lawsuit for the
families of the shooting victims in the
parkland high school school shooting
broward county school district officials
approved the 26 million dollar payout
you may recall on valentine's day 2018
nicholas cruz shot and killed 17
students and staff at marjory stoneman
douglas high school at least 17 other
people were injured families of the
victims are also being paid nearly 130
million dollars after reaching a
settlement with the department of
justice for its failure to follow up on
tips about cruz in october cruz pleaded
guilty to the 17 counts of murder and 17
counts of attempted murder his defense
team has repeatedly asked that the death
penalty be taken off the table
each time the judge has denied that
request the sentencing phase is
scheduled to begin for cruz in january
in other settlement news the boy scouts
of america reach a tentative agreement
to compensate survivors of sexual abuse
this settlement offer increased now by
800 million dollars makes it the largest
sex abuse settlement fund in history the
compensation fund is expected to exceed
2.6 billion dollars in february 2020 the
boy scouts of america filed for
bankruptcy as the organization faced a
flurry of hundreds of sexual abuse
lawsuits the settlement offer will be
divided among more than 82 000 boys and
men who say they were sexually abused as
boy scouts
switching gears now and on to alec
baldwin and the shooting investigation
that resulted in the death of a
cinematographer on the set of the film
rust that happened in new mexico and
sheriff's detectives have requested a
search warrant for actor alec baldwin's
cell phone investigators want to look at
the actors past calls photos videos and
messages to learn any new information
about what happened 42 year old
cinematographer helena hutchins was
killed and the director joel souza was
injured when baldwin fired a weapon on
the set last october that gun was
actually a prop but had a live round in
it baldwin claimed in his first
interview about the shooting that he
never pulled the trigger
investigators conducted interviews after
the shooting which made them aware of
emails and text messages about the
production and that led to a warrant for
baldwin's phone after the actor and his
lawyers refused to hand it over without
one the warrant says the film's armorer
hannah gutierrez reid said baldwin was
not supposed to pull back the revolver's
hammer
she claims that someone tried to
sabotage the set
so let's bring in taylor coss of defense
attorney and terry austin who's here as
always uh taylor i want to start with
you a lot of attorneys when i posted
about this on twitter said that they
feel this is a fishing expedition but is
it possible that the investigators know
more than they're saying and what
they've been what they've put in the
affidavit for the warrant
so that's possible you would think that
they would put their best foot forward
and let the judge know who's going to be
evaluating the affidavit for the search
warrant everything they have because
they don't want to get you know they
don't want the judge to deny the warrant
but at the same point it is possible
that they know something that they're
not telling us this is a tabloid
frenzied case and if anything leaks then
it would you know it would get around so
quickly and perhaps hamper the
investigation you know it's interesting
to me or you know i want to know are
they looking for things that were on his
phone leading up to the incident uh
perhaps admissions of behavior on set
things like that or are they looking for
post-incident admissions from baldwin
that might go to prove his negligence it
will be interesting to find out what
they're actually looking for and what if
anything they find
it will be interesting to see what they
find and actually you know we should
mention that uh helena hutchinson's
phone was mentioned in this and the fact
that she had been sending and receiving
texts for a couple of months about the
production before it started so terry
i'm wondering what your thoughts are
about them wanting to look at alec
baldwin's phone what do you think of it
well i think it's strange that he
initially refused to voluntarily produce
it i mean what is he trying to hide he's
not going to delete anything so why not
just produce your phone i think
authorities based on what taylor was
saying want to know before and after
what did he know about any safety
problems and the crew and also after
what did he admit maybe he did pull the
trigger so it'll be interesting to see
what is in that phone
it certainly will be and we're going to
keep close tabs on that all right moving
on now straight ahead on law and crime
daily the jury hears closing arguments
from both sides in the federal fraud
trial of theranos ceo elizabeth holmes
plus the defense is wrapping up its case
and has wrapped up its case actually in
the federal sex crimes trial of gelane
maxwell that's still ahead on law and
crime daily
[Music]
welcome back the jury will start
deliberating soon in the federal fraud
trial of former theranos ceo elizabeth
holmes this comes after the prosecution
and the defense made closing arguments
to the jury
on thursday the prosecution told jurors
that holmes had the chance to be honest
but that she instead chose to defraud
her investors prosecutors said quote
that choice was not only callous it was
also criminal prosecutors argue that
holmes's text messages and emails show
she knew about theranose's shortcomings
and intended to commit fraud the defense
meanwhile countered saying the
government's case didn't give the full
story saying there were some missing
witnesses and that the case was more
complicated than the prosecution said
defense attorneys also reminded the jury
that they can only return a guilty
verdict if they believe holmes is guilty
beyond a reasonable doubt holmes is the
founder and former ceo of theranos a
silicon valley lab touted to be a
breakthrough blood testing company she
is accused of lying about the technology
to investors to get more funding she
once claimed the now defunct company
theranose would revolutionize blood
testing but later tests found many
issues with the technology holmes is
charged with two counts of conspiracy to
commit wire fraud and nine counts of
wire fraud if convicted she could face
20 years in prison plus be ordered to
pay restitution to her investors so
let's bring taylor costs back in along
with terry austin taylor
15 weeks of testimony that's a lot to go
through
where do you think the jury starts with
this and how long do you think they'll
deliberate
i mean this could this could be a doozy
this could be a long one
a lot of stuff
to absorb but i do think in terms of
where they will start i thought the
prosecutor was really effective
when they looked at the jury in the eye
and said listen
don't convict
her based on anything that i'm saying
convict her on what she said her own
words her own text messages her own
statements and her own admissions even
the admission for instance that she
fabricated reports by putting the pfizer
logo in the top you know corner why
would she do that if she knew it was
legitimate little things like that so
over the course of these months of
testimony they've heard tons of
communications and things that she
herself said that could lead to the
belief that of course she knew uh her
product was not what she said it was
and terry just briefly um what do you
think is going to happen with this case
will she be convicted
you know it's all going to depend on
what that jury sees are they sympathetic
do they think she's just being attacked
because she's a woman because other
companies have failed or do they think
she intentionally tried to defraud all
of those people so we'll see what they
have to say but she could face 220 years
in prison if she's found guilty on every
count
yeah we shall see
all right when we come back galaine
maxwell's defense has wrapped up they
were expected to call dozens of
witnesses but they didn't and did she
take the stand we're going to talk about
all of that when we come back
[Music]
welcome back and we're on to new york
now where the defense has rested its
case in the federal sex trafficking
trial of british socialite gelane
maxwell and this comes after the
defendant herself maxwell said she would
not be taking the stand in her own
defense now on friday maxwell addressed
the judge saying quote the government
has not proven its case beyond a
reasonable doubt so there is no need for
me to testify maxwell a british
socialite and former companion of
jeffrey epstein faces six felony sex
crimes charges prosecutors say she
recruited and groomed young teenage
girls for epstein for sexual abuse
epstein faced similar charges in 2019 he
died by suicide in his jail cell before
his case went to trial maxwell's defense
says she's a scapegoat for epstein the
defense was actually going to call as
many as 35 witnesses but it seems only a
handful
took the stand friday morning her team
asked for more time to locate the
witnesses but the judge said
no dice she denied that request and said
the defense should rest if they could
not find the witnesses
now the
three witnesses did testify one of them
being an ex-girlfriend of epstein's uh
that woman was brought up in testimony
last week by one of maxwell's accusers
who said that that woman and her husband
were her first sexual encounter after
her training by maxwell now let's bring
taylor coss and terry back in taylor
i'll start with you
um you know did the defense do a good
enough job here of defending glenn
maxwell against these charges
probably not uh probably not you know
there is no jeffrey epstein so the face
of this tragedy is glenn maxwell and you
know what what was once promised to be a
big hearty defense kind of fell apart at
the last minute and uh i
i don't feel strongly uh that that she
did enough uh to get out of the shadow
of jeffrey epstein
terry do you think that uh maxwell made
the right decision by not taking the
stand
i do think that was the right decision
even though this is a he said she said
sort of case i think here she would have
been cross-examined and that would have
been extremely difficult for her to
defend all of these actions and i think
you know the
defense made the right decision here to
just keep her away and let the evidence
you know speak for itself
all right
and we'll see how it'll shake out thanks
for joining us and we'll see you next
time as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you